tom and jerry are literally one of my  favorite cartoons  it was important to have the animated  characters be in 2d  because the classic cartoons were in 2d  boom  we could actually have them look exactly  like they always did but at the same  time live  in the 3d world  they're still going to be somewhat 2d  which is really cool  we thought it was the best way to give  homage to what the cartoons have always  been  what i am proud and what i do physically  allows them to be able to animate even  more  i'm sorry he's a little animated  animation and  real people collide in a very exciting  way  this movie synthesizes these elements in  a cartoon that i grew up on and loved  there's a certain charm to tom and jerry  just make you smile  it's really decadent to watch it's a fun  world  [Music]  [Music]